alors oui sébastien nous l'a dit nous
sommes très près d'une campagne
électorale alors c'est l'heure des
bilans
surtout pour le gouvernement en place
alors la question ce soir
est ce que le gouvernement marois a
respecté ses promesses les réponses avec
hugo lavallée
on n'a pas vraiment chômé depuis 2012
pauline marois l'a répété sur tous les
tons son gouvernement dit elle a
respecté la plupart de ses engagements
on voulait faire bouger le québec
je pense qu'on l'a fait bouger le
résultat est là un groupe de chercheurs
de l'université laval qui a étudié les
promesses du pq lors des dernières
élections
nuance ce constat selon eux seulement
56% des engagements du parti québécois
ont été réalisés ou sont en voie de
l'être
c'est certain que le parti québécois a
lancé réalisé tout un tas de promesses
symbolique
et puis ensuite il ya eu un attachement
jde son élection pauline marois a body
la hausse des droits de scolarité et la
loi 12 encadrant le droit de manifester
elle a aussi annoncé la fermeture de
gentilly-2 et le retrait des subventions
pour l'exploitation de l'amiante
le gouvernement fait adopter une série
de lois en matière d'intégrité
notre gouvernement est en train de faire
un sacré ménage
mais sur le front budgétaire le bilan
est plus mitigé
pauline marois s'était engagé à
équilibrer les finances publiques mais
l'échéancier a été repoussée la taxe
santé sera annulée elle a plutôt rendu
progressive aujourd'hui les électeurs
québécois sont très pour le professeur
françois pétry l'objectif du déficit
zéro a retardé la réalisation de
plusieurs engagements
sauf sein des implications sur tout un
tas d'autres mesures qu'on ne peut pas
réaliser aussi autant qu'on aurait voulu
sur le plan identitaire le parti
québécois a tenté de respecter ses
engagements avec sa charte des valeurs
toujours débattue et son projet de
refonte de la loi 101 qui a avorté
la charte a aussi forcé le gouvernement
à mettre en veilleuse d'autres projets d
énergie se sont mobilisés derrière ce
projet qui aurait peut-être pu pu se
mobiliser dans un autre projet le statut
minoritaire du gouvernement et la durée
de son mandat explique bien sûr en
partie son échec à respecter toutes ses
promesses
des prévisions budgétaires trop
optimiste durant la dernière campagne
ont aussi rendu plus difficile
l'atteinte de ces objectifs ici hugo
lavallée radio canada québec